guys i'm so excited because it is my
favorite time of year i absolutely love
the holidays and the holidays also means
project for awesome tons and tons of
youtubers participate in project for
awesome every year and it's just a
really cool feeling to be able to know
that we're all coming together as a
community to do something good for other
people now my charity that i've chosen
this year and past years is charity
water they help bring clean safe
drinking water to developing nations and
we're going to build another well some
of our past projects for awesome wells
are currently being built right now
sometimes it takes a year or two to get
them turned around you get a gps
location of where your well is being
built you get to really see
what you've done and how you've helped
change people's lives so if you guys
would like to donate for this year's
project for awesome well the link is in
the description below feel free to click
through and let me know if you guys
donate if you can even just donate a
dollar i mean that's more than not a
dollar if you see any other project for
awesome videos be sure to like favorite
comment because we really want to help
make this year even more successful than
previous years check it out if you guys
were thinking about getting me something
for christmas here you go christmas time
let's build a well merry merry christmas
happy holidays and um
yep that's it happy project for awesome
2012. see you later